I mean 19 years is like more that's
longer than people keep their kids in
their house
I feel super happy yeah Ellen Pompeo has
no regrets about scrubbing out from
Grace loan trying to reinvent the show
and continually trying to reinvent the
show is the challenge at this point Jack
chatting on the Drew Barrymore show the
actress opens up about exiting one of
TV's biggest phenomenons you've
announced that you're leaving graze how
do you feel it feels super happy really
yeah
um but listen the show has been
incredible to me and and I love I've
loved
a lot of the experience listen it's just
I gotta you know I gotta mix it up a
little bit I'm 53. I gotta do some new I
gotta do something new or I'm gonna
literally turn into like you know you
can't do the New York Times crossword
puzzle every single day as Ellen sees it
her tenure on the show's grown into a
teenager and now it's time to leave the
nest
I mean 19 years is like more that's
longer than people keep their kids in
their house
like people keep their kids in their
house until they're 18 and then they
send them off to college
so this is like me like going away to
college kind of and as Ellen prepares to
say goodbye she's got plenty of support
from her co-stars she said this herself
she's never going to like fully leave
she's an executive producer I don't
foresee you know like Grace without gray
and I imagine she'll pop back in and out
too you know um but who knows I I don't
know what what they've got in mind but I
love what they've done this season I
think Ellen is very much involved with
the show we're at Grace Sloan Memorial
and the hospital itself is kind of one
of the central characters back in August
Ellen gave fans a heads up that she'll
have a reduced role in season 19. you're
okay that's all I care about and now we
know Meredith Gray's getting a formal
send-off on February 23rd ending a
journey that started back in 2005
alongside her on-screen husband Patrick
Dempsey who left the show in 2015 but
has since returned in flashbacks she's
leaving the this show
um I don't know if you heard because she
got caught stealing Band-Aids from the
set they uh
finally they caught her imagine what she
would have in her house now from oh if I
ever get a whole hospital I'm headed
right there yeah yeah Patrick and Ellen
go way back and after nearly two decades
their bond is Unbreakable that was a
very special bond it was just there was
a magic to our connection you've had a
lot of handsome co-stars on the show was
there anyone that was easier to kiss
um listen you know I love Patrick
Dempsey I love him
and and
him and I had a great time together and
and I also love Scott Speedman my
current love Speedman is hot
speed is very hot
but fast forward to 2022 Ellen's busy
writing her next chapter I have a lot
that I'm doing
um I have three kids
and
um so I take care of them and it's
really important for me to be around for
them and be more present for them I'm
going to do a limited series for Hulu
um in the spring which is a very cool
like kind of crazy true story yep she's
lined up her next gig producing and
starring in what's for now simply known
as Untitled orphan project I'll be right
here when you're ready
[Music]
thank you